[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
researchers say the pandemic has
deepened america's epidemic of
loneliness among young adults ages 18 to
25 a staggering 61 percent reported
serious loneliness during the pandemic
now as our jamie wax shows us one new
york woman is on a mission to help
strangers meet each other at indoor
gatherings
if your name is marissa please listen up
it all began with a rather unkind video
while out for a walk drew harden
overheard two strangers planning a party
part of their plan to exclude a friend
named marissa they are choosing to do it
the weekend you're away it's quite
frankly everyone's worst nightmare your
friends doing you know mental gymnastics
to not invite you to a birthday party
the 23 year old recorded what he heard
posted it to tick-tock and asked users
to find this marissa tic toc helped me
find marisa the post went viral viewed
more than 14 million times within a day
23-year-old marissa mize was identified
it ended up getting back to me and i
was i mean just
sad it was sad i got one text message
basically confirming that it was them
and that was it marissa pushed through
the sadness and pain turning her
unexpected social media fame into a
mission of inclusivity a bunch of people
were messaging me i would love to be
your friend let's meet up let's hang out
i am lonely i'm sad whatever and i took
that and i was like why not
have everyone meet up in one place to
meet each other
we are having our first friend picnic
meetup born with no more lonely friends
a movement where strangers meet up
safely outdoors at central park once a
month for a picnic it creates a safe
space for new friendships to form i
never expected more than i don't know 20
30 people and when like 200 people
showed up just
blows my mind
the popularity of no more lonely friends
has moved beyond the big apple with
marisa hosting picnics in other cities
like boston and l.a
is this a story about
something beautiful that came from all
of us feeling isolated during the
pandemic i think uh it was a really cool
thing to see so many people be so open
with their mental health during the
pandemic there were parts that you were
so isolated and so coming together with
everyone
being like this together is just so
just so amazing strangers she can now
call friends including drew who started
it all with his tick tock post i was so
inspired by her response to be like you
know what
i'm good i'm moving on i think it's
really powerful just to speak to how
important friendships are and how
starved of it we've been during the
pandemic marissa hopes to continue
connecting lonely strangers together and
has a goal to host picnics in all 50
states
it's a free event that everyone is
welcome no matter what age and
just i just would love for more people
to know so that they can make friends
too and just feel welcome as everybody
else does no more lonely friends no more
lonely friends for cbs this morning
jamie wax new york
love it i love it they say social media
is isolating but apparently not